En este video vamos a profundizar un poco más
en la destilación, en particular aprenderemos a
construir e interpretar las curvas de destilación.
Digamos que estamos tratando de destilar
aproximadamente 50 mililitros compuestos por 50%
de acetato de metilo y 50% de acetato de propilo.
Si no sabes qué son el acetato de metilo o el
acetato de propilo no hay problema, lo interesante
aquí es la diferencia en su punto de ebullición.
El punto de ebullición del acetato de metilo es de
56.9°C, mientras que el punto de ebullición
del acetato de propilo es mucho más alto,
101.5°C, de modo que podemos imaginar que con esta
configuración de destilación fraccionada vamos a
poder separarlos con bastante facilidad debido a
esas diferencias en el punto de ebullición. Así
que lo que hacemos es empezar a calentarlo,
vamos a tener que calentarlo hasta el punto
de ebullición de la mezcla, que va a estar en
algún lugar entre estos dos puntos de ebullición,
probablemente serán 70 y algo grados Celsius.
Ahora, una vez que consigamos que esto hierva,
se van a empezar a formar muchos vapores más, esos
vapores van a ser una combinación de acetato de
metilo y acetato de propilo. Sabemos que a esa
temperatura, si estamos por debajo del punto
de ebullición del acetato de propilo, un número
desproporcionado de esos vapores serán acetato de
metilo, y luego, como se trata de una destilación
fraccionada, esa mezcla de vapores va a tener
múltiples ciclos de condensación y revaporización,
y a medida que llegan más y más alto, cada vez que
se condensan y luego se vuelven a vaporizar esos
vapores de vaporizados van a tener una proporción
aún mayor de acetato de metilo. Y lo que veremos,
a medida que aumenta gradualmente la temperatura,
es este anillo de condensación, que podemos
ver como el límite entre donde hace suficiente
calor para que se formen suficientes vapores y en
donde no hace suficiente calor para que se formen
suficientes vapores y se condensan. Y podemos
imaginar que justo en donde está ese anillo de
condensación inicialmente va a estar más o menos
en el punto de ebullición de acetato de metilo.
Así que mientras esta temperatura tenga lecturas
bastante bajas, tal vez justo al principio,
no va a generar mucho destilado. Realmente no
vamos a generar mucho destilado hasta que este
anillo de condensación se acerque bastante
a donde está el bulbo de este termómetro,
y esos vapores puedan empezar a entrar en este
tubo de condensación. Ahora, podemos imaginar que
en el momento en el que el anillo se suba por acá,
significa que los vapores, la mezcla de vapores,
ha tenido múltiples ciclos de condensación y
vaporización, que es equivalente a múltiples
ciclos de destilación simple; de modo que para
cuando el anillo de vapor llegue aquí tendremos
principalmente vapores de acetato de metilo y la
temperatura aquí, el punto de ebullición de los
vapores aquí arriba, será aproximadamente el punto
de ebullición del acetato de metilo. Pero ese es
el punto en el que empezamos a ver que muchos de
esos vapores son capaces de entrar en el anillo de
condensación y condensarse, y estamos empezando
a producir mucho destilado. Así que a 56.9° C
aproximadamente, comenzamos a producir mucho
destilado. Ahora, podemos imaginar que durante
el tiempo en el que estamos haciendo esto tenemos
que aumentar lentamente la temperatura de la
mezcla. ¿Cuál es la razón? Bueno, como empezamos a
perder cada vez más vapores de acetato de metilo,
entonces el punto de ebullición de la solución
aumentará. Como dijimos, esta solución original
es de unos 50 mililitros, así que una vez que
obtengamos alrededor de 20 mililitros de tu
acetato de metilo destilado, no vamos a poder
producir mucho más destilado a esa temperatura,
vamos a tener que seguir aumentando la temperatura
hasta que aquí el bulbo alcance la temperatura del
punto de ebullición del acetato de propilo.
Así que seguimos aumentando la temperatura,
no vemos mucho destilado nuevo, tal vez un poco
más y obtenemos cada vez más acetato de propilo,
así que esto será especialmente una mezcla
de vapores. Estamos obteniendo lo último del
acetato de metilo, pero estamos obteniendo una
mayor cantidad de acetato de propilo. Una vez
que esté lo suficientemente caliente en el
punto de ebullición del acetato de propilo,
a unos 101°C, empezamos a producir mucho más
destilado, y estos son esencialmente vapores
de condensación de acetato de propilo. De
modo que si quisiéramos separar estos dos
lo que haríamos en esta primera fase cuando vemos
esta meseta y vemos que se produce mucho de este
volumen en el punto de ebullición del acetato de
metilo, podríamos tener un pequeño tubo aquí o
un pequeño frasco y luego podemos cambiarlo por
otro en esta fase antes de que suba demasiado
la temperatura. En seguida podemos recoger la
condensación del acetato de propilo. Ahora,
también podemos ir al revés. A menudo podrían
presentarnos una curva de destilación como
esta y decirnos "¿Cuáles fueron aquí los puntos de
ebullición de los componentes?", y diremos, bueno,
la sustancia de punto de ebullición más bajo lo
podemos ver aquí. Pudimos obtener mucho destilado
cuando el bulbo estaba a esa temperatura, de
modo que ese debe ser el punto de ebullición de
la sustancia 1, e incluso podríamos identificarla
si conocemos el punto de ebullición de diferentes
sustancias. Y luego identificaríamos esta meseta
como el punto de ebullición de la sustancia número
2. Algunos de ustedes podrían estar pensando que
esto está bien para la destilación fraccionada,
pero ¿cómo se vería realmente la curva de
destilación simple? Bueno, recordemos que
en una destilación simple no tenemos varios
ciclos de condensación y revaporización,
que es equivalente a múltiples ciclos de
destilación simple, de modo que cuando esté lo
suficientemente caliente como para que los vapores
lleguen aquí, tendremos menos acetato de metilo
puro será una combinación de los dos, seguirá
habiendo una desproporción de acetato de metilo,
pero el punto de ebullición de esa combinación de
mezclas va a ser mayor. Así que lo que sucede es
que empezamos a obtener una cantidad significativa
de destilado a una temperatura más alta. Y todo
eso un poco más gradual cuando estamos haciendo
destilación simple frente a la fraccionada.
Podemos imaginar que si alguien presentara
una curva de destilación simple como ésta,
será mucho más difícil identificar los puntos
de ebullición de las diversas sustancias porque
en cualquier punto dado tenemos más mezcla de
vapores que cuando hacemos destilación fraccionada